[موسيقى]
احذر من الذي يسامحك بلا حدود لانه ان رحل
لن يعود فمن يتجاهل اخطاءك ليس مغفلا هو
فقط لا يريد خسارتك لكنك اذا تمديت سياتي
يوم لا يستطيع فيه سماع اعذارك فان جرحت
احدا لا تعاتبه على رده فعله على جرحك له
لان قلوب الطيبين الاوفياء شفافه كالزجاج
قابله للكسر الى العناوين
الامم المتحده تعلن بدايه عصر الغليان
انقلاب النيجر يهدد فرنسا بالعتمه
بوتين سيوزع الخبز على فقراء افريقيا
عين الحلوه والواقع المر للفلسطينيين
هل بدات السويد والدنمارك بالتراجع
اتهام خطير من صحيفه جزائريه للامارات
والمغرب
في اليمن عز القبيله بلاده ولو تجرع وباهه
كهرباء مصر افضل من كهربائي اوروبا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا الحمد لله ما في برد لا احد يشعر
بالبرد فقد بدا عصر الغليان على ذمه
الامين العام للامم المتحده هو غليان
عالمي مترافق مع غلاء دولي معطوف على غلو
عسكري عابر للقارات غير المستقرات من اسيا
الى اوروبا في افريقيا
اهلا بنا جميعا في حضره شهر تموز حيث تغلي
الماء في الكوز فلا حاجه لتسخينه
بالكهرباء لكن الكهرباء حاجه لتبريد
الهواء فماذا تفعل الشعوب المبتلات بوزراء
قصر في حكومات نصبت فرانكلين واديسون
العداء هما اكتشف الكهرباء وهم اخترعوا
قطع الكهرباء دائره
انتهى عصر التغير المناخي وبدا عصر
الغليان العالمي
الهواء غير قابل للتنفس والحراره لا تطاق
ومستوى ارباح الوقود الاحفوري وتدهور
المناخ غير مقبول عندما ولد في النيجر قبل
63 عاما لم يكن ابواه يدركان انهما يربيان
زعيما ملهما لقاده العالم هذا الرجل هو
محمد بازوم واللي بيعرف بيعرف واللي ما
بيعرف بيقول عنه ماذوم لكن رئيس النيجر
الذي اعتقله بعض عسكره وانقلبوا عليه
انقلبت الدنيا تاييدا له من مجلس الامن
الدولي الى الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي والاتحاد الافريقي الكل يريد
عوده بازوم وانهاء الانقلاب المقود
للديمقراطيه والاستقرار بطبيعه الحال لكنه
ليس الانقلاب الاول خلال السنوات الاخيره
في افريقيا
والذي يعتقل فيه الرئيس ويموت احيانا في
ظل كواتم صوت دوليه
وكاله سبوتيك الروسيه وصفت بزوم بانه احد
اخر مؤيدين الغرب في افريقيا لكن الكرملين
دعك غيره الى عوده الشرعيه
باريس عاصمه الوصايه الاستلباصيه الجبريه
على النيجر كما يصفها خصومها تحولت الى
غرفه عمليات عسكريه برئاسه ماكرون الذي
هدد الانقلابيين اذا مسوا مصالح فرنسا في
بلادهم
ظهر الالاف من مؤيدين انقلاب في النيجر
امام مبنى الجمعيه الوطنيه هو امام
السفاره الفرنسيه فينيامي وحملوا لافتات
تطالب بخروج القوات الاجنبيه من اراضيهم
ورددوه هتافات ضد فرنسا ومؤيده لروسيا
الرئيس الفرنسي منويل اعلن لن يتسامح مع
اي هجوم ضد فرنسا ومصالحها في النيجر حسب
بيانا لقصر الاليزيه هل تعلمون ان فرنسا
ترى النور من ثقب النيجر المظلمه بشهاده
رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا والتلفزيون الالماني
وصحيفه تايمز البريطانيه
فعلى النيجيريين ان يفيقوا كل صباح
ليؤمنوا من مناجمهم اليورانيوم لاضاءه برج
ايفل وعموم فرنسا ثم ينام تسعون بالمئه من
اهل النيجر اصحاب اليورانيوم بدون كهرباء
تشكل النيجر اهميه كبيره لفرنسا هذه
الاستراتيجيه تتمثل في دعم الجيش هناك
بدلا من التواجد العسكري المباشر على
اراضي افريقيا منطقه عولت عليها فرنسا
لتشغيل مفاعلاتها النوويه اذا توفر لها
اليورانيوم الذي يسهم في انتاج نحو 70% من
الكهرباء في فرنسا واذا فقدت باريس هذا
المورد فان ازمه الطاقه ستزداد سوءا بشكل
ملحوظ بحسب صحيفه تايمز البريطانيه لا
تعطي الدروس لاحد يا ماكرون خطاب سابق قاس
من رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا جيولوجيا ميلوني
المليانه غيظا من غطرسه فرنسا كما تصفها
في النيجر وفي عموم افريقيا ربما لان
ايطاليا المهتزه اقتصاديا تتحسر على
ماضيها الاستعماري والذي لم تحافظ عليه كم
فعلت فرنسا لكن فرنسا يبدو انها بدات بحزم
حقائب العوده او الترحيل من افريقيا يعني
غضب المدام جيولوجيا مش نابع من عشقه
للسمره الافريقيه
يعد افريقيا بضمها الى نادي الكبار الواعد
القادم لا محاله بحسب بوتين الغارق في
اوكرانيا اذا قام جيشه بسلامه من متاهتها
[موسيقى]
يعلن بوتين على هامش القمه الروسيه
الافريقيه في سان بطرسبورغ ان فقراء
افريقيا سياكلون الخبز الروسي مجانا
وفريدي بدون كلفه نقل فهل هناك اي طلبات
من كريم ورفيق على اجنحه السنونو بلادنا
قادره على تعويض الحبوب الاوكرانيه على
اساس تجاري وفي شكل مساعده مجانيه للدول
الافريقيه الاكثر احتياجا نضمن ايضا
التوصيل المجانيه لهذه المنتجات
للمستهلكين موظف في سفاره غينيا بروسيا
اخذه الحماس قليلا للرئيس الروسي فوضع
صورته على قميصه لان سيده الكرملين يريد
ان يوحد العالم يقول فهل بدا بوتين بتوحيد
العالم من اوكرانيا يسال مراقب ويشيد
بلباقه الرئيس الروسي في التعامل مع ضيوفه
من زعماء افريقيا حيث اصر على احدهم
البقاء جالسا رغم وقوف بوتين
[ضحك]
في المؤتمر الختامي للقمه الروسيه
الافريقيه استذكر بوتين ابطالا بارزين في
تاريخ القاره السمراء بينهم شيخ المجاهدين
الليبي عمر المختار فسال معارض سوري لو ان
عمر المختار كان في سوريا ابانا التدخل
العسكري الروسي ضد الثوره هل كان سيقف الى
جانب المفتي السابق بدر حسون
يهللان لجيش روسيا
جمال عبد الناصر
احمد ابن
امراه المختاره كم يوما ستحتاج لترتيب
استسلام رجالك
نحن لن نستسلم
ننتصر او نموت
ولا تظن انها نهايه
سيكون عليكم ان تحاربوا الجيل القادم
والاجيال التي تليه
[موسيقى]
غصب عن قولتك وغصبا عن المستوطن تبعك هاي
ارض فلسطينيه هذا الفلسطيني الشجاع
المدافع عن وجوده ضد الاستيطان شرق نابلس
يوجه رساله بدون مجامله الى الامناء
العامين للفصائل الفلسطينيه الذين اجتمعوا
في مدينه العلمين المصريه
حرروا القضيه من خلافاتكم او تحرروا من
مسؤولياتكم ايها الامناء العامين اذا لم
تختخذوا قرارات حاسمه لقياده شعبكم وتحرير
ارضكم فتنحوا فتنحوا واتركوا المجال
للشباب الصاعد ان يكونوا المرحله وان
يقارعوا هذا المحتل وامل ان يقول لنا لقاء
اخر قريب على ارض الشقيقه الجمهوريه مصر
العربيه
لنعلن الى شعبنا انهاء الانقسام واستعاده
الوحده الوطنيه الفلسطينيه امل الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس بلقاء قريب
وباستعاده الوحده نسخه متجدده من خطاب
متكرر تربى عليه جيلاني جديدان وهذه عينه
تحضر من الارشيد واعضاء الفصائل الذين
اجتمعوا في العاصمه المصريه في محاوله
لبدء التطبيق وكسر الجليد اتفقوا على
تشكيل لجنه مصغره لتسميه اعضاء اللجنه
التي ستشرف على اجراء الانتخابات لرفعها
للرئيس الفلسطيني رضينا باستمرار الانقسام
اذا وقف عند هذا الحد فما يجري في مخيم
عين الحلوه بلبنان يكرس الواقع المر
صحيح ان المشهد بات يتكرر في كل فتره في
مخيم عين الحلوه الا ان المعركه هذه المره
رفعت من عداد الضحايا شراره المعركه
انطلقت مع اطلاق نار استهدف النشاط
الاسلامي محمود ابو قتاده ما ادى الى جرحه
رصاصه كانت كفيله بان تشعل معركه بين
مقربين من حركه فتح واخرين من الجماعات
المحسوبه على الناشطين الاسلاميين
الفلسطينيون يقتحمون مراكز اخوانهم
والمتطرفون الاسرائيليون يواصلون
اقتحاماتهم للمسجد الاقصى المبارك
اقتحامات اقلقت امريكا وبريطانيا فهل
يبادر الرئيس الامريكي والرئيس الوزراء
البريطاني الى تناول ادويه مضاده للقلق
عقب اقتحام ما يسمى وزير الامن القومي في
حكومه الاحتلال اعتماد للمسجد الاقصى رفقه
المئه من المستوطنين في زياره استفزازيه
ليست لهم اعربت كل من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والمملكه المتحده عن قلقها من
هذه الاقتحامات المستمره لباحات المسجد
الاقصى المبارك
كنا نعتقد حتى الامس انه فاقد للحس بما
يجري من حوله لكنه نطق اخيرا على قدر ما
يعرف ويفهم رئيس الوزراء السويدي الف
كريستارسون قلق جدا من عواقب استمرار
تدنيس المصحف الشريف في بلاده فهل يتصل
بواشنطن ولندن لاخذ وصفه ادويه القلق التي
يستعملونها
الف افندي انت متطوع بالصليب الاحمر ام
رئيس حكومه مؤتمن على استقرار بلدك وحمايه
مصالحه
لم يكد الرجل ينهي كلامه حتى تكررت للمره
الثالثه جريمه احراق نسخه من المصحف
الشريف بحمايه من شرطه كريستارسون وعلى يد
ابن العراق العاق الارهابي المطلوب بجرائم
حرب والذي قالت وكاله الهجره السويديه
انها تعيد النظر في تصريح الاقامه الممدوح
له اقدم المجرم المطلوب دوليا سلوانك على
ارتكاب جريمه جديده بحق القران الكريم
وذلك بعد ادرام النيران بنسخه من المصحف
امام مبنى البرلمان السويدي هذا وافادت
وكاله الانباء السويديه بان موميكا لديه
تصريح بالاقامه المؤقته من المقرر ان
تنتهي صلاحيته العام المقبل الدنمارك
تتحدث ايضا لاول مره انها ستدرس سبلا
قانونيه للحد من احراق نسخ من الكتب
المقدسه لكنه يبقى كلاما حتى الان
والامثال الدنماركيه تقول كثيرون يمدحون
الحق ويفعلون الباطل هذه الاحتجاجات وصلت
الى مستويات يتم في النظر الى الدنمارك في
اجزاء كثيره من العالم كدوله تسهل اهانه
وتحقير ثقافات وديانات وتقاليد البلدان
الاخرى الهدف الاساسي من بعض هذه الاعمال
كان الاستهزاز ويمكن ان يكون لذلك عواقب
وخيمه بكل الاحوال اصبح الاعتداء على
الرموز الدينيه والكتب المقدسه انتهاكا
للقانون الدولي بقرار من الامم المتحده
فهل تستفيد منه الدول الاسلاميه
لمقاضاه اي عابث بالرموز المقدسه ام انها
ستستحي قرار اممي يستنكر اي اعمال ترتكب
ضد الرموز الدينيه والكتب المقدسه
ويعتبرها انتهاكا للقانون الدولي واعتمدت
الجمعيه العامه المكونه من 193 عضوا
القرار الذي صلغه المغرب بتوافق الاراء
ونص على السنكاري جميع اعمال العنف
القائمه على اساس الدين او المعتقد وطلب
القرار بادانه جميع الهجمات التي تستهدف
القران باعتبارها اعمالك كراهيه دينيه
[موسيقى]
مره جديده تتحدث وسائل اعلام جزائريه
محليه عن خلافات بين الجزائر والامارات
رغم نفي الخارجيه الجزائريه قبل نحو شهر
من الان تسريبات مماثله الجديد جاء من
صحيفه وصفت بانها مقربه من دوائر صنع
القرار في الجزائر
والاتهامات هذه المره من بينها تزويد
المغرب بانظمه تجسس على جارتها الكبرى فهل
الصحيفه خرجت عن النص الرسمي ام انها
رساله بالبريد المضمون
عنونه صحيفه الخبر الجزائريه صفحتها
الاولى ونشرت معلومات تقول ان الامارات
تحاول اثاره الفوضى في الجزائر الصحيفه
المقربه من دوائر صنع القرار في الجزائر
نقلت عن مصادر قالت انها موثوقه ان ابو
ظبي مدت المغرب بنظام تجسس على البلاد
وتقوم من جهه اخرى بجر موريتانيا الى
الالتحاق بقافله المطبعين مع اسرائيل ملك
المغرب محمد السادس اكد في خطاب ذكرى
توليه العرش ان المغرب لن يكون الا مصدر
خير لجاراته متطلعا الى فتح الحدود
والقلوب مع الحكومه الجزائريه يتساءل
الاديم من الناس العلاقات بين المغرب
والجزائر وهي علاقات مستقره تتطلع لان
تكون افضل
وفي هذا الصدد يؤكد مره اخرى لاخواننا
الجزائريين قياده وشابه ان المغرب لن يكون
ابدا مصدر اي شر او سوء وكذا الاهميه
البالغه التي نوليها لروابط المحبه
والصداقه والتبادل والتواصل بين
ونسال الله تعالى ان تعيد الامور الى
طبيعتها ويتم فتح الحدود بين بلدينا
وشعبنا الجارين الشقيقين ينصح شيخ تونسي
مواطنيه الاعزاء بملا اوقات الانتظار
بالاستغفار اثناء وقوفهم الطويل في طوابير
الخبز امام الافران مشهد اضحى مالوفا منذ
اشهر امام المخابز طوابير طويله من
الباحثين عن رغيف خبز لم يعد يتوفر الا في
ساعات الصباح الاولى وبكميات محدوده معزز
السالمي امام مسجد بتونس عزل عن الخطابه
بعد ان انتقدت تفوت السحيق للاجور بين
المعلم والفنان لانه لم يعرف قدره ولم يقف
عند حدوده مع اهل الفن خطبه الشيخ في
ولايه القيروان جاءت بعد عزل حكومي ل 350
من مدراء المدارس واستمرار حجز الرواتب
اكثر من 17 الف معلم ردا على تحركات
احتجاجيه اطلقتها نقابه المعلمين
التونسيين
ضحكت من شهرها امم امه تقدر المغني مغني
صعد فوق الركع في بلادنا ساعه الا ربع
خمسه واربعين دقيقه فنال راتب معلمين لا
ثلاثه لا خمسين لا
فناذ راتب الف معلم قبل اكثر من شهرين
كشفت وكاله الاناضول التركيه تفاصيل اتفاق
سري بين رئيس حكومه الوحده الليبيه عبد
الحميد الدبيبه والجنرال خليفه حفتر على
تشكيل حكومه موحده وقبل يومين ثلاثه فوجئ
الشارع الليبي بتصريحات لنائب الدبيبه
وزير الصحه رمضان بوجناح يشيد فيها
بمناقبيه نجل الجنرال خليفه صدام حفتر
ويقول انه على خلق
صدام حفتر ابدا نجلس معه والله العظيم
والله العظيم شخصيه محترمه جدا جدا ولا
تسمع الكلام ابدا شاب خلوق ومحترم جيل
الاعلام تسمع الاعلام احنا مشكلتنا
التشويه ربما يقصد نائب رئيس الحكومه
تشكيله من الاخبار والتقارير الاعلاميه عن
جانب من الاتهامات الدوليه والمحليه لصدام
حفتر بقياده جرائم قتل وسرقه واغتصاب
خليفه حفتر وابنه صدام يدخلان ليبيا
موسوعه جينيس للارقام القياسيه باكبر
عمليه سطو مصرفي في تاريخ البشريه وكان
موقع انتلجنس اون لاين قد وصف مرحله
التحول في حياه صدام من لص الى عقيد لواء
طارق بن زياد تابع لخليفه حفتر تحت مجهر
منظمه العفو الدوليه اشار التقرير الى
ارتكابه سلسله من الفضائع بما في ذلك
عمليات القتل غير المشروع والاخفاء القسري
والاغتصاب والتهجير القسري وكان قدر
اليمنيين ان تلحق بهم الحروب حيث محل
فالرحله من اليمن الى السودان هربا من
الحرب لم تكن اكثر خطرا وصعوبه من رحله
العوده الى الوطن وتحمل ظروف الحرب والجوع
فيه فالمثل اليمني يقول عز القبيل بلاده
ولو تجرع وباهه خليت خلاله انها كانت
الجثث يعني كنت انا بعيني لما كنا نمشي
كنا نشاهد الجثث
رحله العوده الى اليمن كانت رحله صعبه جدا
وبسبب الاوضاع الاخير اللي حصلته اندلعت
حرف السودان حتى تم جيران بسفينه حربيه
غير مجهزه يعني فيه وكانت زوجته وضعت يعني
في ميناء السودان
يستمر انقطاع الكهرباء في مصر وتعفى من
ذلك المناطق السياحيه التي تستجلب العمله
الصعبه يؤكد الرئيس الحكومه المصريه مصطفى
مدبولي فالسائح لا ينفق اموال السفر
لتجربه العتمه
مدبوله اعلن عن اجراءات لمعالجه مشكله
الكهرباء لكن من يقنع ياسمينه الحكومه
المصريه بوجود مشكله كهرباء اصلا وزيره
البيئه المكيفه ياسمين فؤاد تقول ان شبكه
الكهرباء في مصر افضل من شبكه الكهرباء في
اوروبا عندنا تكييف بس هم ما عندهمش
الحكومه المصريه بررت انقطاع الكهرباء
بنقص كبير في الوقود والغاز رئيس الوزراء
المصري مصطفى مدبولي قال ان بلاده سوف
تستورد ما تصل قيمته الى 300 مليون دولار
من
للتغلب على انقطاع الكهرباء المتكرر اما
وزيره البيئه المصريه ياسمين فؤاد فقالت
ان مصر وضعها افضل من اوروبا وان الاخيره
لديها مشكله اكبر لعدم وجود مكيفات في
المنازل على عكس مصر
ليس فقط في مناطق الاثرياء والسياح بل
الكهرباء متوفره ايضا لتعذيب المساجين
بحسب مواطن يقول ان شقيقه قتل تحت التعذيب
في قسم للشرطه
محمود محمد عبد الجواد تم اخذ محمود من
اسفل كوبري نبض العلوي يوم
21/7/2023 محمود قام مركز نمرو جميع
افراده بالتعدي على محمود بالضرب والاهانه
وقاموا بضربه ضرب مبرح وبعد ما تم اخذ
محمود في الداخل في المركز اعتادوا على
محمود تعذيب وصاحب الكهرباء
مما ادى الى وفاه اخويا
[موسيقى]
ختاما اذا كان نقل الكفر ليس كفرا فكيف
يكون نقل الخبر ارهابا من يقتنع منكم بان
نشره الاخبار خطه تدميريه وان اجراء حوار
وصفه عبثيه وان مناقشه الاسعار خيانه
وطنيه كيف لقاض اقسم على صون الحق
والعداله ان يسجن الصوت ويعتقل الصوره
ويجرم الراي الحر
اما وقد اعتبرتم الصحافه جريمه فاشهدوا
اننا جميعا مجرمون الى اللقاء اذ استنكرت
شبكه الجزيره الاعلاميه اعاده ادراج
السلطات المصريه عددا من صحفييها على
قائمه ارهاب جديده وذلك بعد انتهاء مده
تصنيفهم ظلما في القائمه التي تجدد كل خمس
سنوات كما دنت الامم المتحده حبس الصحفيين
والتضييق عليهم في مصر
[موسيقى]